Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier (Hi :3)
and welcome to The Midnight Shift--
Ohhh.
Well, we're right into that.
Now in the previews for this game and all the screenshots that I saw...
there's a gratuitous amount of mannequins.
In fact the normal w-
hey-hey-hey.
I was inside the snack machine.
I'm sorry about that :/
(As you should be)
Okay.
So if you know me,
you know that I don't like mannequins.
And a gratuitous amount of mannequins
just so happens to be anything
more than ze...ro?
Ehhugh. (The wails of the disturbed markimoos)
EHHUGH! (more wails of the disturbed markimoos)
Well god damn,
I don't like thaugh---I don't like that at all.
Can you guys see anything in the flashes of light from the lightning?
Cuz I cannot.
Ehhugh. This side up.Okay.
We're surrounded by Big Box Barrys.
Where's Tiny Box Tim to save-- euugh.
Oh!
Hey! It's a mannequin.
Just gonna wander right by that and hope nothing bad happens to me.
OOokAy!
Alright! I am going to die.
Alright.
So awfully disturbing how this poster is expricitly Darkiplier.
Alright, ok, sleepiness is a safety hazard.
Whatever you say.
I suppose, that's, a,
subtle way of telling me not to sleep on the job
OH BOY!
Legs!
My favorite pastime!
Alright.
What am I supposed to do with legs?
Ugh.
Alright. There's something glowing over here.
I can only assume that I should stare casually at it.
*spooky high pitched noise* (save us Mark ;-;)
WWWEEELLL!!
Rumbly dumbly in my tumbly. Let me take the key.
Okay! Well! Got that! I'm sure nothin' changed.
No mannequins did done reassemble around me-uh.
Hey, leg. How you doing? All right? Sure are a lot of legs here. Oh?
Hi.
How are you doing? Great. Me too.
OH. Hi! How are you doing? Great! Me too!
Hi! Are you missing a leg there? Me too!
Oh!
Nice-- *loud clinking noise*  AAAYY!
Why...did...any-OH! Hi! Oh? Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi!
Okay. "I don't like this place." Huh, no kiddin'?
Oh, I didn't know that my memoirs were here, strewn about the place.
Okay, if any of you sacks of shit decide to move and stand behind me,
I'm gonna be INNNcredibly pissed off,
not enough to do anything, but enough to lash out like a cornered animal,
I'd bare my teeth and kind of like scratch at you or something like that
Oh. Hi. Oh *nervous laugh*
Is that a present, for me? Well you shouldn't have! You really really shouldn't
Eeugh
Okay, well, heh heh heh
This is a bad sign if ever I saw one, alright, oh hi.
*High pitched ringing*
My favorite TV show!
All right,  see ya. See ya around. Storage room, eh?
Ehhh, all right,
Well gotta move forward then.
Oh, GOOD! I'm glad we stored a lot of mannequin parts! Those are gonna be awfully helpful!
"Please clean up after yourself." How 'bout no?!
I just pissed my pants.
I shat on the floor in the corner! You expect me to clean that up?
NO!?!
Got a job to do and it ain't that.
Ugh!
Also why are my eyeballs a bad VHS tape?
Okay, all right, exit is locked.
WHELP
I guess I'm going back. I don't know how to deal with a problem as conundrum-ess as that.
Alright, who's around the corner?
Eenie meenie miney moe, catch a tiger by the toe you
If you are a mannequin, go fuck yourself.
Oh, nice ass, alright. Hello. How are you? You good?
Ugh.
All right, well at least say don't seem to be autonomous which is like a gueh-
Which is, like, a good thing.
Yeah, once they start charging after me, that's when I start running really fastly.
OH
D-DAT ASS
*Jumpscare* *Mark screams like a girl*
I DON'T-
OKAY
Eh
Not so bad, you just dropped a bunch of heads on me
I've dealt with worse, and I'm still coming for that booty
swiggity swooty
Alright, swiggity swooty, I'm going away from- Oh. Well that's not good.
Oh-hahhah, hey! Did I- oh no, no, no.
Ahh! You stop that right now!
You-- *perturbed grunting* Hi, hello friend. How are you? Why are they all--
Okay, ah, praise the Sun. I'll just be on my
wayyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyy🎵
Oh, what a
*scared singing* 🎵 Happy day 🎵
Hi. Whoo, nice, okay, all right then,
*giggling nervously* I-don't-like
I don't like you. I don't like you. At least you're not staring at me. Okay, here I go
I hate this. Eeaahh
Eeahh, what is that? Is it an exit key? Great! I'll take that, good. What happened?
*spoopy noises* I DON'T LIKE IT
I'll put it back
I'll put it back. I swear
Okay, all right. We're fine. Hey. How's it going friendly hug? No- AIE!?
Mm-hmm hi nice ass. All right. Hello. How are you? Just minding my own business.
I HATE EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS *Spooky rumbling*
Okay, all right, if you could stop rumbling. Praise the Sun.
*primeval Mark noises*
Hi, don't mind me. Just gonna meannnder my way out. 'Scuse my spit.
Hi-hey-ho
UHH.
Hi. Oh, no! You've had an unfortunate leg accident.
Uhh. All right, you know I wasn't thinking of going back anyway
So you guys can just, you know, have fun.
By yourself. On your own. In this hellhole.
*increasingly more panicked* Hi, hello, hi, hello, uEAHEAHEAH.
Hello, hi.
*weird mark noise*
I don't know what is is about mannequins-- euh, hi-- I just hate them
*creeky metal noise*
*Large bang*
Well that did nothing. *same noise and bang* Gah, it took two tries. Okay, got it though. I got it. Oh this looks
Woah-oh.
Whoa-ho, HI. HOW ARE YOU DOING?
Okay? We'll pretend like that didn't happen
"We know about your problem"
Is it mannequins, or is it all the poop in my pants?
I can't decide which problem I'm more concerned about at this juncture
Okay, all right,
*Marki-warble* *screech (from the game)*
Was that you or was that me? Getting a little bit of compression up in here
Alright, hi. Oh, you seem to have a problem too.
I don't like you, okay
Alright
*panicked giggle*
Yeah, this goes swell--Ahh
WHAT?!
All- All right. Guess I'm free...?
What the hell?
Play the credits I guess
Eeugh
*Sniffles*
Okay, why did this- hee
Why did this game need an executive producer?
Huh. "Check out my other works".
I don't think I want to. All right, Edmund in digital arts college.
Oh, I had a FLASHLIGHT!?
Well I'd'a- Oh.
Why would I ever have wanted to turn that off?
That's my initial question there.
Also, what does this note say?
Storage key is missing. Oh no.
Oh God. Ow God my neck is so tense.
Now that I'm out of that game. I can see how silly that was
Ah God. I'm such a bitch baby.
I'm SUCH A BITCH BABY. I don't like mannequins!
I never have! I don't know what it is about them.
I hate mannequins.
Like this is, like this is a decent game.
It's obviously got some thought put into it.
It's not super polished, but... God damn, I hate mannequins!!
I don't even know what it is.
I don't know what it is about mannequins. I just hate mannequins. I can't stand them.
I don't like them. I don't like them
Anyway, this has been Midnight Shift, uh it needs some work.
There's a lot of other things that need to be put into it before it's a real game but not too bad.
Plays into my phobia pretty well, so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought down the comments below.
And as always, I will see you... in the next video.
BUH BYEE!!!
🎵End Screen Music🎵